one of the things I do on this program
is I tell you honestly and directly when
a political issue is merely a political
football and has a public-facing debate
that is essentially meaningless now one
such issue that is a political football
is debt and deficit we've talked about
it endlessly Republicans claim to care
about debt and deficit until a
republican is President and then when
George W bush blows up the deficit When
Donald Trump blows up the deficit they
say nothing and then now they're back on
it because Joe Biden is President it's a
meaningless political football it
doesn't get into the meat of when is
national debt good bad problematic
interest on the debt Japan China holders
of the you know all these different
things doesn't get to it it's just a
meaningless political football it's a
deflated football we could call it
another such political football
whose public debate is meaningless is
gas prices now if you've been listening
to our podcast for a while if you've
been watching this show for some time
you know I never played into this my
position whether the president is a
Republican or a Democrat is presidents
have some but relatively little to do
with gas prices over the long term and
you can fact check me on this go back
and check out my Clips during past
presidents and you will find that I've
been consistent I don't play the gas
price games whether it's during Trump in
2018 in a clip called gas prices hit
three-year High where I say this has
little to do with Trump it's mostly
seasonal or you go back to 2015 under
Barack Obama in a clip called 1.99 gas
returns or I say this really doesn't
have to do much with Barack Obama there
are probably about a dozen or so clips
that we've done about this issue in
general gas prices go up in the summer
when demand is higher they go down in
the winter when demand is lower in
general Global Supply issues rather than
an American president impact gas prices
and right now gas prices are up about 18
to 20 percent over the last few months
and very quickly once again you are
starting to see the hot takes blaming
Joe Biden and the story that they are
telling is Trump kept gas prices low Joe
Biden came in and gas prices have
skyrocketed now neither is true in a
causal way and we're going to look at it
but some examples the official
Republican Twitter account tweeting
quote President Biden's energy agenda
will raise gas prices even higher by
shutting down American energy production
that's not true here's Republican House
minority leader and it gives me great
pleasure to remind you he's the minority
leader Kevin McCarthy including gas
prices in his sort of grievance list
against Joe Biden just a few days ago
look what has happened in the short
amount of time they've control bold all
your gasoline price is up Biden has
created a crisis on the border that he
won't admit there was also a widely
shared Facebook post whose basic message
was when sleepy Joe came in diesel was
1.69 today diesel is 319. thanks to all
that voted for this clown now the
numbers are wrong in that post but the
causality is also gone so I could go on
and on with more examples but here's the
truth this has nothing to do with Joe
Biden and it started before Joe Biden
was president first of all gas prices
move on a delay in response to oil
supply issues it's a much slower process
than some Republicans want you to think
right now and in this case we know why
gas prices are up it's the inverse
reason of why they were down in 2020.
the price of oil and thus gasoline
collapsed in 2020 due to no demand
it costs money to store oil and when
demand for gas is down you don't
necessarily want to keep refining oil at
the same clip because there's not demand
for it so you store the oil and demand
was down so much due to the pandemic
people not flying people not commute
commuting Cruise industry shut down that
the price of oil and gas collapsed now
as vaccination is rolling out as cases
are declining as air travel is returning
as commuting is returning demand is
increasing and it's actually in some
areas increasing very quickly so gas
prices are going up globally it's not
just in the United States this has
nothing to do with Joe Biden but then
here's the cherry on top many republican
talking points require not understanding
how time exit time works or believing in
time travel
if you look at a chart of gas or diesel
prices here's a chart of diesel prices
up on the screen you will notice the
increase started in October under Donald
Trump and it simply continued during
Trump's presidency in November in
December the first two thirds of January
then Joe Biden took over and the gas and
diesel price increase is continuing and
it is related to demand coming back
as the pandemic hopefully starts to wane
don't fall for this stuff it'll rot your
brain as uh as as I like to say and it's
not borne out by the facts it's not
borne out by the data it is not Joe
Biden's fault that gas prices are up and
importantly gas prices being up is a
good sign that demand is returning and
hopefully if we keep vaccinating if we
start getting vaccines to more countries
more quickly and we continue vaccinating
more quickly
um we will we will see a significant
economic improvements that yes might go
with uh you know a tank of gas costing a
few dollars more for the average
consumer vehicle today's episode is
sponsored by Blue chew a unique online
service delivering the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's supply for free take a
short quiz on the Bluetooth website a
licensed doctor approves your
prescription and the medication goes
right to your home in a discrete package
no driving to the doctor's office having
a possibly awkward conversation waiting
in line at the pharmacy Bluetooth
replaces the entire process with a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
Bluetooth tablets are made in the United
States so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence go to
bluetooth.com the link is under this
video and they'll give you an entire
month supply for free when you use promo
code Pacman just pay five dollars for
shipping